youna grows two varieties of pears Bossk
and Anjou
she took a sample of each variety to
test if they're a ver egde caloric
contents were significantly different
here is the summary of her results were
here is a summary of her results and so
they give the same data for both of
these samples and once again they happen
to have the same sample size they don't
need to but over here instead of giving
us a p-value we have we've gotten a
confidence interval Yuna wants to use
these results to test her null
hypothesis that the mean caloric content
is the same versus her alternative
hypothesis that they are different
assume that all conditions for infants
have been met based on the interval what
do we know about the corresponding
p-value and conclusion at the alpha is
equal to 0.01 level of significance so
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out remember what a 99%
confidence interval is that says that if
we construct confidence intervals 100
times that 99 of those times we should
overlap with the true parameter that
we're trying to estimate in that case
the true parameter is the true
difference of these means now when we do
a hypothesis test we always start
assuming that the null hypothesis is
true and so if we assume that the null
hypothesis is true well another way of
writing this null hypothesis if the two
means are equal that's the same thing as
the difference of the means equaling
zero and since we're assuming this and
this is a 99% confidence interval then
ninety-nine out of a hundred times that
we do this we should see that this
interval overlaps with what we're
assuming is the true parameter right
over here now this interval does indeed
overlap with deer if you take 4 minus
6.4 4 you're going to get negative 2
point 4 4 so 0 is definitely in the
interval and so another way to think
about it we're not in the 1 percent of
the times where we don't overlap if we
were in the 1 percent of times where we
don't overlap with the assumed
difference then we would reject the null
hypothesis
or another way to think about it is our
significance level 0.01 right over here
it's 1 minus our confidence level right
over here if our 99% confidence interval
overlaps overlaps with MU from the bosk
pairs
minus the mean caloric content of the
Anjou pears equaling zero then that
means that means that the p-value is
greater than 0.01 and so we could also
say that our p-value is greater than our
significance level because that is our
significance level and because of that
we fail to reject our null hypothesis if
this did not overlap with our assumed
difference in the means if it did not
overlap with zero then we would be in
that one in a hundred scenario and then
that would tell us that hey our p-value
is less than 0.01 our p-value is less
than one minus our confidence level and
in that case we would reject the null
hypothesis and it would suggest that
there is a difference in caloric content
but because we fail to reject it we
can't conclude that there's a difference
in caloric contents